lonna Idris loves mathematics she
majored in law and Islamic studies all
that helped her in her banking career I
aim for solutions and results in the
last 15 years of my career I've seen
banking go from a highly respected
professional field to the boogie man of
the nation if not the world since 2009
she's been head of compliance process
management and outsourcing at the bhf
Bank in Frankfurt overseeing 120
employees I'm very much a team player I
like being the boss but it doesn't give
me a feeling of power I think that's
something I have difficulty developing
anyhow even though I see it happening
all around me I always try to use
persuasion if one plus one is two then
somehow that's clear and we can't do it
any other way
Lana Idris was a business consultant
when she was offered the management job
at the bank she says to this day that it
was the right step because it gives her
time to help eight projects get going
as a sign equality it's a conservative
thing a very traditional bank but it's
also a family-oriented Bank even though
I'm in a leadership position
it lets me reduce my workload to 90
percent which gives me the opportunity
to help Society she devotes her days off
to Geetha until a year ago it was an
association now it's also a company
helping Syrian refugee women lonna Idris
has Syrian roots her father comes from
ohms when the country plunged into chaos
she felt she simply had to help she's
turned her home into company
headquarters coworkers and friends lend
a hand and of course so does her son on
her website she sells handbags towels
and accessories decorated with beautiful
traditional embroidery I'm holding a
lovely hand embroidered piece
it comes from Shatila refugee camp in
Beirut which has existed since the 1950s
forty thousand people crammed together
in a square kilometre we work with an
organization called bas me and situ nee
which means a smile and an olive to
produce these items I've just brought
this back from Beirut in the past twelve
months she's been in the region five
times
the Syrian women who work for her lead
dangerous lives we found out that two
women who worked for us were arrested
the grounds were completely irrelevant
they were far-fetched in any case one of
the women has now been released but the
other hasn't and that means we have to
be extremely careful not to use their
names and if so only the first name and
never pictures or photos on social media
in her spare room she stores everything
she brings back from her visits 600
women work for Gaia the company
guarantees it will buy everything they
produce one of her latest projects and
products on the website are glasses from
Beirut the artist who made them put
together the production facility himself
there's the Syrian artist who collects
old bottles with street children and
makes glasses out of them I asked how I
could meet him and if anyone knew him
and I did meet him and I saw these
gorgeous glasses they're all made out of
old bottles but you'd never know it
Germans are so eco-friendly surely they
will really like these lonna
eaters takes the packages with the
towels handbags and glasses to the post
office herself that's set to change
I'm not and if I can do this so can lots
of other people I'm convinced of that at
some point I realized that my life was
incredibly full of time-wasters let's
start with the most simple thing turning
on the TV and sitting in front of it for
two or three hours that's 2 or 3 hours
that you could really be doing something
useful for yourself and for others
you